Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. This is going
to be my Jessica Jones episode video. Just
because of the way everything is dropping,
these videos are going to work a little different
but this is going to be all about episodes
1 through 4. Just careful for spoilers if
you haven't started watching Jessica Jones
yet and there really is no right way to watch
it because these Netflix they drop it all
once you could totally do that raise your
hand if you actually stayed up all night to
finish every single episode nobody that I've
seen on twitter Facebook has made it past
like episode 10 yet so most people watch like
a block episodes take a break and come back
later will start off of the really interesting
fact about the series itself just like the
actual production of it the show runner Melissa
Rosenberg said that originally they were selling
the project to ABC and I think were all really
glad that an end up happening because as they
had done this series for ABC it would not
be nearly as cool as it is now they would
had a tone all the cool stuff down it would've
been way less dark way less gritty way more
formulaic when it was still at ABC the Patsy
Walker character was intended to be Carol
Danvers that's right Capt. Marvel what happened
is as this is a long time ago way before avengers
interval Tron went down if you member she
was originally supposed to be in avengers
interval Tron two Capt. Marvel but plans change
the Jessica Jones TV show went to Netflix
Marvel studios ended up changing their movie
plans and Capt. Marvel got her own movie so
they had to take her out of the Netflix series
and put in the Patsy Walker hellcat character
and if you're not familiar Patsy Walker is
hellcat from the comics she does have special
powers that all talk about as I as or talk
about all the characters but as much is there
a bunch of references to the comic books in
this Jessica Jones TV series it's not as connected
to the MCU as it used to be when it was at
ABC the party line was just like agent to
shield everything is connected to Netflix
shows are still technically connected because
they reference a lot of things that happen
in the movies but they don't we've been with
the plot quite as much like they don't expect
a whole bunch of Civil War set up in this
is a my initial reaction to the series is
that it is a better character-based TV show
than anything else Marvel has done or really
anything else with on TV right now daredevil
is an amazing TV show it's also better than
most TV shows in existence but it's more of
a traditional crime drama Jessica Jones is
more of a character study to you just drilling
deep into everyone's psyche why everyone is
doing what they're doing daredevil does take
the time to get into the character's heads
but not nearly as much as Jessica Jones so
I feel like people that will walk away liking
daredevil more than Jessica Jones are just
of a fan of more traditional plot based TV
shows that they are fly contents character
study like one of the big seems that everyone
is talking about is what Jessica Jones and
Luke Cage have superpowers sex like there's
there's a couple different times they have
sex the first time they have sex is super
awkward because they don't know each other
as powers just like it's okay I'm not fragile
I'm not can a break as she is super top new
cage not knowing that she has superpowers
is like no you will definitely break I need
to slow down for the fact that they're having
sex isn't that special characters are allotted
TV shows have sex is the way Jessica Jones
portrays it sex scenes it's super intense
and superpersonal and because the Jessica
character hasn't really come out of her shell
as of the first couple of episodes she is
she like she can handle the intensity so that's
why when she's staring at Luke Cage she get
that weird look on her face and she has to
turn around she can't look him in the eye
when they're having sex is just too personal
for her until we get to episode three when
she starts to come out of her shell little
bit we finally come clean about their powers
their back stories and becomes a much more
traditional comfortable sexing despite the
comedy of them breaking everything with their
super sex spam, and I think my favorite funniest
moment in the first four episodes at least
one Jessica finally gets so paced with her
upstairs neighbors making noise that she bangs
on the door and finds out that they're twins
and it turns into this weird game of thrones
Quinn says joke I don't give a bag in Dixville
kinda kinky sugar into as long as you do it
quietly favorite line so far in the series
her upstairs neighbors are actually good barometer
for what's going on inside her head she starts
out she can't handle people she's in super
loaner Moche like I can't be around people
on the danger to people and people are endangered
to me like I don't know what's going to be
around the next corner so she just isolates
herself but finally because of this hope case
and kill great coming back she gets sick of
areas like fine almond to do something about
it so that's kind of reflected in the way
she treats her upstairs neighbors and then
eventually she gets a little more comfortable
with their weirdness even though she still
calls them out on it like when the dude tells
her that they have tinfoil all the windows
and she's like wait a minute I don't I don't
want to know I don't want to know why but
the interesting thing about the Jessica Jones
character yes is like an intense character
study for her but the same issues the Jessica
Jones is dealing with all the other characters
are dealing with them to especially her friend
Patsy Walker you find out with some clarity
is turning yourself into a ninja slowly but
she feels completely powerless like I can't
help I don't have special powers so she is
also kind of locking herself away in her special
fortress from the world the same way Jessica
Jones does let's talk about some of the big
Easter eggs the earliest one is actually the
opening scene where she talks about catching
people bony analysis she gives the evidence
to her client gets all and she smashes him
through the window that's an actual line in
a panel right out of her alias comic that
really the biggest Easter eggs of the characters
that they pull from the comics Jeryn Hogarth
here who might end up turning into something
of a villain it is certain point crazy intense
shark lawyer who seems like Jessica's friend
or at least gives her jobs this is a gender
bent version of Jeryn Hogarth from the comics
in the comics it's a male character he works
for Rand Meacham he's also a lawyer for Rand
Meacham is the any rants families company
is like their version of Wayne Enterprises
so that's the connection to iron fist the
Jeryn Hogarth character there is a lot of
rumors going around about the iron fist Netflix
series maybe it's happening maybe there doing
something different with it Joe Casada actually
just said that they are working on an iron
fist Netflix series so I would take him at
his word but the interesting thing about Jeryn
Hogarth is that they turned it into a much
bigger character than she has her own subplot
that's going on with her wife here in the
person she's married to is calamity Jane from
deadwood which I think is just awesome but
there's this whole thing with her cheating
getting divorced from her and then she finds
out about kill grave and she's like wow the
things that we could do if we could make him
work for us and of course when Jessica hears
her wondering about that just like WTF this
person is a psychopath so kinda wondering
if the Jeryn Hogarth character is going to
try and save kill grave from Jessica Jones
so that she can use him for her legal practice
because she was talking about this big $50
million case so just put a tab in that like
Jeryn Hogarth might wind up being one of the
villains of the series even though she starts
out seeming like a friend Jessica really needs
to find some new attorneys if if only there
were some avocado pros the could help her
out the second the character I was in the
Patsy Walker hellcat character the really
interesting thing about the way the tease
characters out is how they explain their back
stories like Jessica throws Patsy's mother
in her face and she's like a low blow just
but you don't find out about her mother till
many episodes later so the tease back story
with the turn of phrase and then actually
explain it in a later episode so I just I
love the way their seating stories out it's
really like one story told over 13 hours instead
of a traditional TV show for you have a different
story every single week when my favorite moments
is one Patsy Walker accidentally takes down
that fan and then he says I really miss the
red hair is just a reference to her comic
book character in the comics Patsy Walker
when she does have her hellcat powers has
red hair was talk about Luke Cage he's obviously
going to be getting his own TV series and
Mike my culture actually did say that the
medically stylistically the Luke Cage TV show
will look way different from Jessica Jones
but when Luke Cage is telling Jessica Jones
about his origins he says experiment he was
framed for drug possession thrown in prison
while in prison he was allowed to participate
in the said experiment and it was a modified
version of the Capt. America super soldier
program so he was bombarded with this organic
electrical field and that's how he got his
superstrength and his super tough skin it's
a little more complicated than that he was
actually undergoing the super soldier treatment
and another character came in and sabotage
the controls and that led to the accident
the gave him his powers so whereat a timeline
that has already happened in Luke Cage is
just trying to hide out he's out only the
police up in my business you see all this
paranoia about people that are gifted the
use the term gifted with really that talking
about anybody with powers that also includes
in humans like when Jessica serving papers
to that douche bag character and she's like
I have a laser eyes we see very timely Superman
reference but you just you get the sense that
this exists inside the marble cinematic universe
he also referenced the on an attack but haven't
heard any reference to Terrigen Mists or fish
oil pills yet another girl that Luke Cage
has a picture of in his bathroom is his ex-wife
that's a Reva Connors from the comics the
reason Jessica is so sad is because it's the
same girl the kill grave had her kill we don't
know exactly why but Reva Connors was Luke
Cage's girlfriend in the comics before he
became power man on the TV show I received
she runs afoul of kill grave and in the comic
book she runs afoul of diamondback which is
a character that's going to be in the Luke
Cage TV series but if there was any confusion
like this woman is not misty night misty night
is actually going to be a new character in
the Luke Cage TV series so will see her you
can see why they made this change they just
they want to give Jessica some history with
Luke Cage that did not previously exist in
the comic books but if you are confused about
why Jessica Jones was initially investigating
Luke Cage she lies and says that she was on
a case trying to catch him boning with a married
woman but then the woman comes back later
in his like I don't know why you are investigating
him and taking pictures are you a stocker
because my husband did not hire you she was
investigating Luke Cage because she knows
that he is connected to the woman that she
is haunted by the woman that she killed moving
onto David Tennant's kill grave one of the
best marble villains so far and we will is
in a little bit of them he is the exact same
type of introduction the kingpin does during
the daredevil series like you see the back
of their head first you hear them speak but
you don't see their face till later making
the little girl go to the bathroom in the
closet so terrible but your dislike all man
this is going to be so amazing and so awful
for the first couple of episodes is all about
Jessica realizing that he still alive she
thinks that she left him for dead in the same
accident where she killed Luke Cage's ex-wife
but she slowly tracks them down with the big
Gray's anatomy Easter egg which I thought
was hilarious what hospital you from Seattle
Grace oh you mean like the one on TV's we
learned some really interesting stuff about
him he is you know just as psychologically
damaged is Jessica Ernie the other characters
he's completely obsessed with Jessica despite
the fact like Jeryn Hogarth is like all think
of the power that this man has but he uses
his powers for such mundane things like he
just wants to get dinner he just wants to
get Jessica back with the gonna do with her
really small trivial stuff kill grave if he
wanted could be way more powerful because
he has so many psychological problems he's
always going to be tied up doing bowl should
small stuff so you learn about his flaws but
I think one of the most interesting lines
about him in the first couple of episodes
the doctor has that line reads like I told
them you could survive just fine with one
kidney but no he wanted to be made whole and
how completely messed up was it when she went
to visit the person on the dialysis machine
the person who helped kill grave escape his
accident and he writes kill me on that pad
of paper and she's just like I can't I can't
this point of steering your TV going over
my God but here's my big questions for you
guys let me know in the comments what is your
favorite funny moment so far in what is your
favorite most messed up moment so far so what
I'm going to do for my next Jessica Jones
video is all due episodes five through eight
Saunders do like blocks of four episodes I'll
try to do a video every day but I might end
up having to skip Sunday is also a new flash
arrow crossover extended trailer with a bunch
new footage of Hawkgirl Hawkman so do a video
for that later tonight so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and I will be live tweeting
some of the episodes I'll try to be as non-spoil
re-as possible but if you don't know where
my twitter and Facebook are their links in
the description white as way for everything
to post you can click here for my Jessica
Jones playlist is where I'm adding all my
new Jessica Jones videos and you can click
here for the flash arrow crossover trailer
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five and I'll see you tonight